OK, here's something that most of us would never, ever do. When Julia Sweeney's brother got cancer, and then she got cancer, she decided she wanted to talk about it with strangers from a stage in a comedy club. After the worst of all these times was over, she turned some of these stories into a one-woman show, which became a book and a movie.
好了，接下来这事儿我们大多数人绝对绝对不会做。当朱莉娅·斯威尼（Julia Sweeney）的弟弟患上癌症，接着她自己也得了癌症时，她决定在喜剧俱乐部的舞台上，向陌生人倾诉这件事。在所有这些最糟糕的时刻过去之后，她把其中的一些故事改编成了一场单人秀，后来又成了书和电影。
But there's something about these original recordings that she made. During the same weeks that some of the most horrible things that can happen to a person were happening to her, there's something about these recordings which is just very remarkable. Her feelings are right there on the surface.
但她录下的这些原始录音有些特别之处。就在她人生中最可怕的一些事情接连发生的那几周里，这些录音有一种非常了不起的地方。她的情感就那样赤裸裸地展现在表面。
There's this saying that comedy equals tragedy plus time, which isn't always true but is mostly true. And in this case, there is just no time, right? Sometimes you get the feeling when you hear these recordings that she's talking about these things for the very first time with anybody. And it's from a stage.
有句谚语说，喜剧等于悲剧加上时间，这话并不总是对的，但大多时候如此。在这种情况下，根本没有时间去沉淀，对吧？有时候当你听这些录音时，你会觉得她是第一次和任何人谈论这些事情。而且是在舞台上。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. This, of course, is your weekly program documenting everyday life in these United States through whatever means and tactics seem necessary. And of course, most weeks, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme, documentaries, monologues, found tapes, occasional radio plays, anything we can think of.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，这是你们每周一次的节目，通过各种似乎必要的方式和策略，记录美国人的日常生活。当然，大多数时候，我们选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的故事，包括纪录片、独白、现成录音、偶尔的广播剧，任何我们能想到的东西。
But today, what we're going to do is devote the entire program to just one thing, to this very unusual set of comic monologues. Today show's is going to proceed in two acts. Act One, Julia's Brother Gets Cancer. Act Two, Julia is diagnosed with cancer herself and gets treated. These recordings were made between October of 1994 and August of 1995 at a regular weekly comedy show called Un-Cabaret in Los Angeles, run by Beth Lapides and Greg Miller.
但今天，我们要把整期节目只奉献给一件事，就是这一组非常不同寻常的喜剧独白。今天的节目将分为两幕。第一幕：朱莉娅的弟弟得了癌症。第二幕：朱莉娅本人被诊断出患有癌症并接受治疗。这些录音是在1994年10月至1995年8月期间，在洛杉矶一个名为“Un-Cabaret”的定期周播喜剧秀上录制的，该秀由贝丝·拉皮德斯（Beth Lapides）和格雷格·米勒（Greg Miller）运营。
Un-Cabaret started off as this kind of experiment in reaction to the predictability and lowest-common-denominator mentality of a lot of stand-up comedy. The rules of Un-Cabaret were that no comic was allowed to tell a story that he or she had ever told on stage before. So spontaneity was just built into the structure of it. And the way it would work is that every Sunday night, back in its early days, five or six people would go up, often with notes in their hands, onto the stage, and then do this thing that was somewhere between traditional stand-up and diary and a kind of reportage. It had its own very particular kind of feeling to it.
“Un-Cabaret”起初是一种实验，旨在回应当时许多脱口秀中那种可预测性和“最低共同点”思维。“Un-Cabaret”的规则是，任何喜剧演员都不允许讲述之前在舞台上讲过的故事。所以即兴表演被融入了它的结构中。它的运作方式是，在早期的每个周日晚上，会有五六个人拿着笔记上台，做一种介于传统脱口秀、日记和某种纪实报道之间的事情。它有一种非常独特的氛围。
Some quick caveats before we begin. These tapes are made from the soundboard at Un-Cabaret. And so the sound quality isn't always the greatest. Also, sometimes you're going to hear laughing and off-stage comments during the monologues. And these are from the MC and ringmaster at Un-Cabaret, Beth Lapides.
在开始之前有几个小小的提醒。这些录音是从“Un-Cabaret”的调音台上直接录制的，所以音质并不总是最好的。此外，有时候你会听到独白期间的笑声和场外的评论，这些来自“Un-Cabaret”的主持人和掌舵人贝丝·拉皮德斯。
Some things you should know about Julia Sweeney before we start that she refers to in these monologues. She was in the cast of Saturday Night Live for a while. She's best known for a character named Pat. And the joke with Pat was that nobody could ever tell if Pat was a man or a woman. And there was a Pat movie, which, as she refers to, didn't really do too well.
在开始之前，有几件事你需要知道，朱莉娅·斯威尼在这些独白中提到了。她曾经在《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）的演员阵容中待过一段时间。她最出名的角色是“帕特”（Pat）。关于帕特的笑话是，没人能分清帕特到底是男是女。当时还有一部《帕特》的电影，正如她提到的，票房并不是很理想。
So to these tapes. This first bit is from October 23, 1994. And you know how part of being sick is dealing with everybody in your life when you're sick? A lot of the stories that Julia Sweeney tells about cancer are basically just stories about her family. Her brother moved in with her when he got cancer to be near the cancer treatment center very early in his illness. And then her parents moved in soon after that.
现在回到这些录音。第一段来自1994年10月23日。你知道，生病的一部分痛苦在于当你生病时要处理生活中每个人的事，对吧？朱莉娅·斯威尼讲述的关于癌症的很多故事，基本上只是关于她家人的故事。她弟弟在患癌初期为了靠近癌症治疗中心，搬去和她同住。接着，她父母不久后也搬了进来。
OK, my parents are staying with me this week. And when I say this week, I mean it's just the first of many weeks. They keep saying, "Now, we've got to start planning the Thanksgiving dinner." And then my mom goes, "Why are you crying?" And I go, "Oh, my eyes are watering. I have this weird problem with my sinuses." It's a special feeling to be in your mid-30s and have your parents moving in with you.
好了，我父母这周和我住在一起。当我说是这周的时候，我的意思是，这仅仅是漫长几周里的第一周。他们不停地说：“好了，我们得开始计划感恩节晚餐了。”然后我妈问：“你为什么要哭？”我说：“哦，我眼睛进沙子了。我的鼻窦有点奇怪的问题。”三十多岁了还要和父母住在一起，这种感觉真的很特别。
I haven't revealed why my parents are here for so long until this time. And I'm trying to think very hard about the most hilarious way I can get this across. Oh, please be with me tonight. All right. So briefly, there's five kids in our family. I'm the oldest. And my brother, who's the fourth child, got lymph cancer. Hold for laughs. And it's a very tragic, terrible situation, although he's doing very well. And he is at the UCLA Cancer Center. And every day, he has radiation, and every other day, he has a spinal tap and spinal chemo. And every three weeks, he has the big chemo.
我之前一直没透露我父母为什么待了这么久。我正在努力思考用最搞笑的方式把这件事说出来。哦，请今晚保佑我。好了，简而言之，我们家有五个孩子，我是老大。我的弟弟，也就是第四个孩子，得了淋巴癌。（停顿，等待笑声）这是一场非常悲惨、可怕的情况，虽然他恢复得很好。他在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）癌症中心治疗。他每天都要接受放射治疗，隔天还要做腰椎穿刺和脊髓化疗。每三周还要做一次大化疗。
So all you need to know about this is that I am with my parents, but in a very trying situation where I can't really yell at them for the small, annoying things that they do-- which I would do normally-- because of the largess of the total situation. And yet, for you, I can kvetch a little bit. All right.
所以你只需要知道，我正和父母待在一起，但在一个非常艰难的情况下，我不能因为他们做的小事而对他们大吼大叫——虽然平时我会这么做——因为整体情况太重大了。不过，对你们，我还是可以抱怨一下的。好了。
So anyway, suffice it to say, we're at UCLA Cancer Center every day for several hours. My mother-- who is, by the way, the same age as Dustin Hoffman. They were born on the same day. Keep this in mind. Every time we get on an elevator, she acts like it's a miracle invention that she's never encountered before. And you can imagine how many times we get on elevators in a given day. Many elevators. Every time I get on the elevator, even if it's just she and I getting on the elevator, I immediately push the "door open" button because it takes so [BLEEP] long for her to get in the elevator.
总之，不用多说，我们每天都在UCLA癌症中心待上好几个小时。我妈——顺便说一下，她和达斯汀·霍夫曼（Dustin Hoffman）同岁，他们同一天出生，记住这点——每次我们坐电梯时，她表现得就像那是她从未见过的奇迹发明。你可以想象我们一天要坐多少次电梯，很多次。每次我上电梯，即使只有我和她，我也会立刻按下“开门”按钮，因为她走进电梯实在太他妈慢了。
And every time, she goes, "Oh, oh!" when the elevator arrives. And then I go in and push the "door open," and then she goes, "Oh!" And then she takes a moment before she goes over the chasm between the hallway and the elevator itself, that little metal thing. "Hurry up because the doors are going to close automatically!" God!
每次电梯一到，她就惊呼：“噢，噢！”然后我进去按下“开门”，她又惊呼：“噢！”接着，在跨越走廊和电梯之间那道小金属缝隙之前，她还要磨蹭半天。“快点！电梯门要自动关上了！”天哪！
And then, she always get in, and then she looks up like, "Oh!" And then when we go, she goes, [INAUDIBLE GESTURE] And then when they open, she goes, "Oh?" It's like, I really don't think Dustin Hoffman does that. And how many millions of times have we been on elevators together? A billion.
然后她终于进来了，抬头一看，又惊呼：“噢！”电梯一动，她又是一脸茫然，电梯门打开时，她又惊呼：“噢？”我觉得达斯汀·霍夫曼肯定不会那样。我们在一起坐过多少次电梯？十亿次。
So the  other thing is, my mother, she's from that generation that thinks that you would never get a second opinion about anything because doctors know everything. And also, she believes that all doctors have the same amount of knowledge in every area. So we're talking to the lymph specialist, and then we'll be walking down the hall, and there'll be a group of doctors. We know because they're men. And they're not rushing around looking very caring. That's the signal. And then she goes, "There's some doctors. Go ask them if they know about lymph cancer."
还有一件事，我妈那一辈人认为，你不应该对任何事情寻求第二诊断，因为医生什么都知道。而且，她相信所有医生在各个领域的知识水平都一样。所以，当我们和淋巴专家谈完，走在走廊上，碰到一群医生时——我们知道那是医生因为他们都是男的，而且他们看起来并不怎么关心，这就是信号——她就会说：“那有几个医生，去问问他们懂不懂淋巴癌。”
And I go, "We're talking to the lymph cancer specialist in the country. I think he knows the most about lymph cancer. I don't know what these doctors do." And she goes, "Well, I got the home phone number of Dr. Nishamura, my old OB/GYN. And I was thinking you should call him and ask him about Mike's condition." So I go, "Mom, I really don't think a gynecologist who's been retired for 20 years is going to know that much about this."
我说：“我们刚才是在和全国顶尖的淋巴癌专家谈话。我觉得他最懂淋巴癌。我不知道这些医生是干嘛的。”她说：“好吧，我有西村医生的家庭电话，他是我以前的妇产科医生。我在想你该给他打个电话，问问麦克的病情。”我说：“妈，我真的不认为一个退休20年的妇产科医生会对这个懂多少。”
OK, but you wonder, what's Dad doing? He reads. He just buries himself in reading. And then, my dad is a diabetic. Hmm, weird. And then my brother, who is now living with me also, he gives himself shots every day for his blood counts. And so there's just syringes hanging around my house. And so a common thing for me is like, "OK, who left their syringes on the kitchen table? Dad? We have to throw them away and break the needle." All right.
好吧，那你可能会问，我爸在干嘛？他在读书。他完全沉浸在阅读里。我爸患有糖尿病，嗯，真古怪。我弟弟现在也住在这儿，他每天给自己打针来控制血象，所以家里到处都是注射器。我常说：“好了，谁把注射器留在餐桌上了？爸？我们要把它们扔掉，折断针头。”好了。
OK, so this is all an introduction to last Thursday. And then I get to the The Pope, so just wait. OK, so we're in the doctor's office. And Mike, who's doing really great and is responding really well to the treatment, but he's had so many spinal taps that they can't get into his spinal column anymore. So the doctors come in. And my dad's reading about the plague in India, because that's a good diversion. And my mom is looking at the doctors and saying, "Now, he looks single." And this doctor comes in, and he says, "Michael, we can't get into your spinal column anymore. So we're thinking about putting a shunt in your head."
好的，这都是为了引出上周四发生的事。我们要聊到教皇了，等着瞧。我们在医生办公室里。麦克的情况很好，对治疗反应很积极，但他做了太多次腰椎穿刺，医生已经找不到他的脊椎位置了。医生进来了。我爸在读关于印度瘟疫的报道，因为那是个不错的消遣。我妈看着医生说：“哟，他看起来单身。”医生进来后说：“麦克，我们没法再进入你的脊髓了。所以我们考虑在你头上装个分流器。”
And my brother goes, "What?" And he goes, "A shunt." And I go, "A shunt, like an artificial opening to the brain." And Mike goes, "Well, where would this shunt be?" And the doctor goes, "Well, the best place we've found is to put it in the forehead." And Mike goes, "If you think I am going to get a faucet put into my forehead. I'm already 90 pounds and I have no hair. I am not going to walk around for a year with a faucet sticking of my forehead." And my mom goes, "No, I think it's more like a spigot."
我弟弟说：“什么？”医生说：“分流器。”我说：“分流器？就像那种人工大脑开口？”麦克问：“这分流器会装在哪儿？”医生说：“我们发现最好的位置是额头。”麦克说：“如果你觉得我会在额头上安个水龙头，那你就想错了。我已经只有90磅重，而且头发都没了。我绝不会顶着个水龙头走上一整年。”我妈说：“不，我觉得那更像个龙头。”
And then the doctor goes, "But the people we know, the patients that have the shunt, they love it. Oh, they thank me for it because the pain is so much less, and when we do the operation, because it's in the brain, there's no pain." And my brother goes, "Oh, that's because you give them lobotomies before you put the faucet in!" And then my dad's looking up from his article on the plague.
然后医生说：“但我们认识的装了分流器的病人都很喜欢它。噢，他们很感谢我，因为疼痛减轻了很多，而且因为是在大脑里，手术中没有痛感。”我弟弟说：“那是当然，因为你在装龙头前先给他们做了脑叶切除术！”我爸此时从瘟疫的报道中抬起头来。
Anyway, as you can imagine, I got a little depressed that [INAUDIBLE]. So Thursday night, I decided that I wanted-- because, as you may know, The Pope wrote a book, and it came out on Thursday. So I had to be right there to get it. And also, I wanted to get away from my home. So I get into my car, and I'm driving to Book Soup, and sadness, the new current trend in thinking, overtook me.
总之，你们可以想象，我当时有点沮丧。所以周四晚上，我决定——你们可能知道，教皇写了本书，周四刚出版——我必须马上去买。而且，我想逃离家。于是我开车去Book Soup书店，悲伤——这种当下流行的情绪——淹没了我。
And I had no makeup on, a little lipstick, and overalls, which are not a good choice for me. And I looked terrible, but I though I'd go to Book Soup. And then  I started crying. And I started thinking, oh, why, why, why? Why can't it just end? I just don't want to go on. And if I am going to end and I really am just going to be over, why can't I smoke? Because who cares if I get lung cancer? I'm not going live that long to even have lung cancer. So I'm going to buy some cigarettes. Yes! I'm going to buy a cigarette and I'm going to smoke it. And I'm going to go to Book Soup and I'm going to buy that book from The Pope.
我没化妆，只抹了一点口红，穿着背带裤——这对我来说真不是个好选择。我看起来糟透了，但我还是想去Book Soup。接着我开始哭。我开始想，为什么，为什么，为什么？为什么这一切不能结束？我不想再继续了。如果我就要完了，如果我真的要终结了，为什么我不能抽烟呢？反正谁在乎我会不会得肺癌？我活不到那个时候去得肺癌。所以我决定去买烟。是的！我要买包烟抽，然后我要去Book Soup买教皇的那本书。
So I'm sobbing and sobbing. So I get to Book Soup. And I kind of wipe my eyes, and I they're all red and everything. So then I go in, and then suddenly, I'm kind of seized with a moment of embarrassment-- for some reason that I don't understand, since I get embarrassed continually throughout the day with no problem, apparently-- about asking for this book that The Pope wrote. So I come in and I kind of scan the bookstore out to see if there-- I was looking for a big 10-foot cutout of The Pope with his hands out and the book. There wasn't one.
我哭得泣不成声。到了Book Soup，我擦了擦眼睛，它们红肿不堪。我走进去，突然感到一阵莫名的尴尬——我不明白为什么，毕竟我平时整天都在尴尬——因为要买教皇写的那本书。我走进去，扫视书店，看有没有——我在找那种10英尺高的、张开双手的教皇立牌和那本书。结果没有。
So I had to go to the information desk. And I go, "Hi, I'm looking for a book that came out today." And the guy goes, "Oh, jeez, it's right over there." And I'm thinking, "The Pope's doing some business on these books." So I go over to this area, and it's that Resnick Nicole Simpson book. So then I go back, and I go, "No, not the Resnick book. The Pope. The Pope's book." So I go over and I get the Pope's Book, this book. And then I think, oh, I don't really want to just buy The Pope's book.
我不得不去咨询台。我说：“嗨，我在找今天出版的那本书。”那人说：“噢，天哪，就在那边。”我在想，“教皇的书卖得这么火吗？”我走过去，结果发现那是妮可·辛普森（Nicole Simpson）那本关于雷斯尼克（Resnick）的书。于是我折回来说：“不，不是雷斯尼克那本。是教皇，教皇的书。”我走过去找到了教皇的书。然后我想，噢，我其实不想只买教皇的书。
So somehow, I end up in the self-help section. Hmm. And I'm looking at titles like Can You Live Through This? and You Can Make It and Why Do Things Happen to People and stuff like that. And then finally, I find this book-- oh, I wrote down the title. It was An Atheist's Guide to Getting Through the Day. There is a tomorrow. I thought, that's the book for me.
不知怎么的，我走进了自助类书区。嗯。我看着标题，比如《你能挺过这一关吗？》、《你能做到》、《为什么坏事会发生在人身上》之类的。最后，我找到了这本书——我把书名写下来了——叫《无神论者度过难关指南：明天依然会到来》。我想，这正是我需要的书。
So now I have The Atheist's Guide to Getting Through the Day and The Pope's book. And I'm thinking, all right, I think I'm covered. And there's not very many people in the book store, and I keep having to remind you how awful I look. And all of a sudden-- now, this is the most embarrassing thing I'll ever say  at Un-Cabaret-- without any warning, I let out the biggest fart. And I am not someone who has any problem with that. And I also find no humor in that kind of humor. And it's like a whistle has gone off at Book Soup. It's just like everyone looks up. And then I don't how whether to rush out of that area or look around or-- it was terrible.
现在我有了《无神论者度过难关指南》和教皇的书。我想，好吧，我想我已经妥当了。书店里人不多，我得提醒你们我看起来有多糟糕。突然——这恐怕是我在“Un-Cabaret”说过的最尴尬的事了——毫无预兆地，我放了一个惊天大响屁。我可不是那种会因为这种事尴尬的人，而且我也不觉得这有什么好笑的。那声音就像Book Soup里吹响了哨子。所有人都抬起头。我不知道该立刻逃走还是环顾四周——真是太糟糕了。
OK, so right at that moment, this guy comes up and goes, "Julia?" Like, "You heard my call. You recognized my fart." Anyway, I don't recognize him at all. And I go, "Hi." And he goes, "Oh, you don't recognize me, do you?" And I go, [MAKES UNCOMFORTABLE SOUNDS]
就在那一刻，一个男人走过来问：“朱莉娅？”好像在说：“你听到了我的呼唤。你认出了我的屁。”总之，我根本认不出他是谁。我说：“嗨。”他说：“噢，你认不出我了，对吗？”我说：（发出不舒服的声音）
And he goes, "Marshall from The Groundlings." And I go-- who I have no memory of-- "Marshall, oh, Marshall. Here I am. I'm getting the Pope's book. How are you?" And he goes, "So hey, when's the Pat movie coming out?" Big, red eyes. OK, here's my standard response. "They opened it in Houston and Seattle, and nobody went or liked it. So, I don't know."
他说：“我是来自《演艺学校》（The Groundlings）的马歇尔（Marshall）。”我对他的记忆全无，只能说：“马歇尔，噢，马歇尔。是我。我在买教皇的书。你怎么样？”他说：“嘿，那部《帕特》电影什么时候上映？”我顶着红肿的眼睛说：“噢，那部电影在休斯顿和西雅图上映了，没人看也没人喜欢。所以我不知道。”
And he goes, "Oh, so it was a bomb." And I go, "Just because no one saw it, that means it's a bomb? It's a hit to me." And he goes, "Oh, well anyway, I'm sorry." And he goes, "So hey, how's Steve?" And I go, "Oh, well, we got divorced this year, but amicably. And really good friend. He's seeing someone, and we talk every day."
他说：“噢，所以是个烂片。”我说：“没人看就代表是烂片吗？对我来说它是个好作品。”他说：“噢，好吧，无论如何，很遗憾。”他又问：“嘿，史蒂夫（Steve）怎么样了？”我说：“噢，我们今年离婚了，但很和平。我们还是很好的朋友。他正在跟别人约会，我们每天都通话。”
"Oh, no, you guys were the cutest couple."
“噢，不，你们可是最可爱的一对。”
"Yeah, well."
“是啊，嗯。”
And then he goes, "Oh, is your brother still running the box office at The Groundlings?" And I go, "Well, no." He goes, "Oh, what's he up to?" "Well, he's got lymph cancer. Stage four. And so, well, I'm going to go pay for my books."
他又问：“噢，你弟弟还在《演艺学校》管票房吗？”我说：“没。”他说：“噢，那他在忙什么呢？”“他得了淋巴癌。四期。所以，好吧，我去结账了。”
So I put back the atheist book, because I really thought my book is really The Agnostic's Guide to Getting Through the Day. I have a little hope. Not a lot. OK.
所以我把那本无神论的书放回去了，因为我觉得我的书应该是《不可知论者度过难关指南》。我还有一点点希望。不多，但有一点。
So I go out, I go across the street, I buy a pack of cigarettes. So now I'm really going to enjoy myself. I get into the car. My family uses my car all the time for transportation purposes. It's the normal use of a car. And they hate cigarette smoke, like anyone should. OK, so I roll down all the windows, and I'm smoking, and I'm actually starting to feel better because Marshall was just such a horrific situation that you could only feel better. You just had to go up.
我走出店，穿过马路，买了一包烟。现在我真的要好好享受一下了。我上车。我的家人总是为了交通方便用我的车。这是车的正常用途。他们像任何正常人一样讨厌烟味。好了，我摇下所有车窗，抽着烟。我开始感觉好一点了，因为马歇尔刚才的情况实在太糟糕了，除了好起来也没别的出路了。
So I'm smoking, and I'm really happy. And then finally, I'm getting close to home, so I throw the cigarette out. And then I keep driving, and all of a sudden, I smell this really smoky smell. And then I pull into the driveway, and I turn around, and my back seat is on fire. The cigarette has flown back into the car and had ignited my seats in the back. So I get out of the car, and I throw the cigarette out, and I'm feeling very like a girl who's just been smoking pot or something going into the house.
我抽着烟，真的很开心。最后，我快到家了，就随手把烟头扔了出去。我继续开车，突然闻到一股很浓的烟味。我开进车道，回头一看，后座起火了。烟头飞回了车里，点燃了后座。我下车，扔掉烟头，感觉自己就像个刚抽完大麻回家的小姑娘。
Oh, which by the way, the prescribed pot for my brother, so my brother's also just smoking pot all around the house all the time. So I go in, and as soon as  I get in, my mom goes, "I want to use your car keys. I have to go to the store and get something." And I go, "Oh, god, you can't believe what just happened to me. I was driving down Sunset, and this old man smoking a cigarette threw it out of his car. And I noticed, because I thought, smoking is terrible. And I got back, and the cigarette had landed in my car and burnt a hole into the back seat.
哦，顺便一提，那是给我弟弟开的处方药，所以他也在家里到处抽大麻。我进去后，我妈立刻说：“我要用你的车钥匙。我要去商店买点东西。”我说：“噢，天哪，你绝对不敢相信我刚才经历了什么。我沿着日落大道开，一个抽烟的老头把烟头扔出窗外。我注意到了，因为我在想，抽烟真糟糕。结果回来一看，那烟头掉进我车里，在后座烧了个洞。”
And my mom's like, "Oh, that's the most horrible thing I've ever heard." And she's going, "Now, an old man was smoking next to you? And I'm like, "Yes, right next to me. Well, on the passenger-- I had the passenger window open where he would be on the other side of the-- because-- yes. And I noticed him, that creep." And so she goes, "Oh, that's so horrible." So she takes the car and goes.
我妈说：“噢，那是我听过最可怕的事。”她又问：“等等，一个老头在你旁边抽烟？”我说：“是啊，就在旁边。在乘客那边——我打开了副驾车窗，他在车的另一边——是的。我注意到他了，那个混蛋。”于是她拿着车钥匙走了。
And then the next morning, my dad and mom are coming out, and the cigarette that was the culprit was on the driveway. And my dad looks down. I go, "Well, there's the cigarette." My dad picks it up, and he goes, "There's lipstick on it." And I go, "Oh!" And my mom goes, "You said it was an old man." And I go, "Well, Sunset Boulevard, you know."
第二天早上，我爸妈出来时，那个罪魁祸首烟头还躺在车道上。我爸低头一看，我说：“喏，就是那个烟头。”我爸捡起来说：“上面有口红印。”我说：“噢！”我妈说：“你不是说是个老头吗？”我说：“呃，日落大道上，你知道的。”
That was Un-Cabaret in October of 1994. Julia Sweeney's next turn at the microphone-- this next one that we're going to hear-- was three months later, in January of 1995.
那是1994年10月的“Un-Cabaret”。朱莉娅·斯威尼下一次站到麦克风前——也就是我们要听的下一段——是三个月后的1995年1月。
My parents are staying with me. I know I say that every week since September because that, in fact, is practically the case. Anyway, my parents are here because I have a brother who is very ill with cancer. And I don't know if he's doing well or not anymore. But he is very, very ill. So my parents are down. And like any stressful situation, their annoying qualities, their personalities, are heightened because it's a crisis situation. And it's made even more difficult for me because I can't yell at them about it because we are in a crisis. And it's like, how could I really scream at my mother for talking incessantly when her son is so very ill?
我父母和我住在一起。我知道自从9月以来我每周都这么说，因为事实确实如此。总之，我父母在这儿是因为我弟弟患了重症癌症。我不知道他现在恢复得怎么样。但他病得很重。所以我父母过来了。就像任何压力大的情况一样，他们的恼人之处、他们的个性在危机中被放大了。这对我来说更难，因为在危机中我无法对他们大吼大叫。就像，在儿子病得这么重的时候，我怎么能真的因为我妈不停说话而朝她尖叫呢？
So Wednesday night, I go out. And my brother, he weighs 120 pounds and he's 5' 11''. And he's taking lots of drugs, and we don't know if it's for the cancer. And we don't know if we should yell at him about the drugs, but then he has cancer, so you don't really want to get down on someone at that moment for that. Anyway, OK, this is just so sad. I am going to try my [BLEEP] hardest to make this funny, all right?
周三晚上，我出去了。我弟弟只有120磅，身高5尺11寸。他吃了很多药，我们不知道是为了癌症还是其他。我们不知道是否应该为了药物问题对他大吼大叫，但毕竟他得了癌症，所以你真的不想在那种时候打击某人。总之，好吧，这实在太悲伤了。我会尽我他妈的全力把它变得有趣，好吗？
So I go see House Guest because I'm going to see Phil Hartman next week, and I want to have seen it. Although now, I probably shouldn't have seen it. I kept thinking all the way home, what are the scenes I can say you were funny in? Which scene? And he's a very funny guy, so it's too bad, but I guess it's making money. And the whole time I was watching, I was thinking. "Pat doesn't get a national release and House Guest gets a national release?"
我去看《管家》（House Guest），因为下周我要见菲尔·哈特曼（Phil Hartman），我想先看了电影。虽然现在看来我不该去看。回家路上我一直在想，哪些场景能让我说你演得很有趣？哪个场景？他是个很有趣的人，所以很可惜，但我猜这片子能赚钱。整个观影过程中我都在想：“《帕特》拿不到全国发行，而《管家》却可以？”
So this is my Wednesday. So I get home from House Guest, I walk in the house, my brother is laid out on the couch. Literally, he's laid out. He's laying there with his hands on his chest with blankets over him, like, has Mike died while I was at House Guest ? Does someone come rushing up to me and saying, "We don't know which coroner to call." I go, "Oh, Mike."
这就是我的周三。从《管家》回家后，我走进屋子，我弟弟瘫在沙发上。字面上讲，他瘫在那儿，双手放在胸前，身上盖着毯子，就好像——麦克在我去看电影时死了吗？有人冲过来对我说：“我们不知道该叫哪个验尸官。”我说：“噢，麦克。”
And he's like, "I'm feeling better," And I go, "Oh, and you look great." And I go in and my mom intercepts, and she goes, "Oh, hi. I'm so glad you're here because I was wondering how House Guest was because I like Sinbad. And I like him because I watched him on TV. And the TV in the living room doesn't coordinate with the cable anymore. And I don't know how to change that, because I want to watch a movie later. And the movie's on a video. And I don't even know how to put the video into the machine. And I was going to try, but I was making some soup, and the soup started boiling over, and your father is too drunk to deal with it."
他说：“我感觉好些了。”我说：“噢，你看起来棒极了。”我往里走，我妈拦住我：“噢，嗨。真高兴你回来了，因为我一直在想《管家》怎么样，因为我喜欢辛巴达（Sinbad）。我喜欢他因为我在电视上看过他。客厅的电视现在跟有线电视连不上了。我不知道怎么调，因为我晚点想看电影。电影在录像带里。我甚至不知道怎么把录像带放进机器。我本来想试一下，但我在煮汤，汤开始溢出来，而你爸醉得不省人事，没法处理。”
OK. I go into the kitchen. My dad's standing in the kitchen with his drink. He goes, "Hey, how was House Guest ? Because I like that Phil Hartman." And I go, "Oh, it was OK." And then my mom comes running in. She goes, "There's no cat food. there's no cat food." And I notice that all the cats are like, "meow, meow, meow" under my feet. Oh, also, the other thing is, having your parents in your house-- if they're like my parents-- means having every available audio device going in every room. The TV is on in every room of the house that there can be TV, and if there isn't a TV, the radio's going on in that room. So there's just this sound everywhere. And then "meow, meow, meow" of the cats.
好了。我走进厨房。我爸站在那儿，拿着酒杯。他说：“嘿，《管家》怎么样？因为我喜欢那个菲尔·哈特曼。”我说：“噢，还好。”接着我妈跑进来。她说：“没猫粮了，没猫粮了。”我发现所有的猫都在我脚下“喵喵”叫。噢，还有，和父母住在一起——如果他们像我父母这样——意味着家里每个房间所有的音频设备都开着。每个能放电视的房间都开着电视，如果没电视，收音机也开着。所以到处都是噪音。再加上猫的“喵喵”叫。
So I go, "There's no cat food?" And she goes, "I was going to go to the store and get some, but then I didn't know what kind because you said the Friskies had too much fat in it, and [MOCKING SOUNDS]" So I go, "OK, I'll go to Pavilions now. It's midnight, but I'll go and get some cat food!"
我说：“没猫粮了？”她说：“我本来想去店里买，但我不知道买哪种，因为你说Friskies脂肪含量太高，然后（模仿嘲笑声）……”我说：“好吧，我现在去Pavilions。虽然现在午夜，但我会去买猫粮的！”
So I leave, and thank God it was three for $0.89. It was a big sale. And there's nothing like being a single woman in her 30s buying $15 of cat food at midnight. That's a really good feeling. So I buy my cat food, and then I get home. And in the meantime, my dad goes, "The cats were so hungry that I gave them the dry food they hate, and they won't eat it." And I go, oh, and I look down, and the bowls are filled with this dry food they hate that I don't know why I have.
我出发了，谢天谢地，那天三个只要0.89美元。大甩卖。没有比这更棒的了——一个三十多岁的单身女性在午夜花15美元买猫粮。那种感觉真好。我买好猫粮回家。与此同时，我爸说：“猫太饿了，我给了它们平时不吃的那种干粮，它们不吃。”我往下一看，碗里装满了它们讨厌的干粮，我真不知道我为什么会有那东西。
So I go, "OK, well, I'm just going to throw that out." And then my dad goes, "No, I'll save that dry food for later. I have a Tupperware bowl out for it, to put in the dry cat food." And he's got one side of the cat food bowl and I've got the other. And I'm going, "No, no, no. I'm just going to throw it away." And he's going, "No, no, no. I'm just going to put it in the Tupperware." And I'm going, "No, no, no. I am really willing to just toss caution to the wind and throw this cat food away." And he's going, "No, no, no."
我说：“好吧，我直接把它扔掉。”我爸说：“不，把干粮留着，我有个特百惠（Tupperware）碗，可以放干粮。”他抓住碗的一边，我抓住另一边。我说：“不，不，不。我就是要把它扔掉。”他说：“不，不，不。我就是要把它放进特百惠里。”我说：“不，不，不。我真的想把谨慎抛之脑后，把这猫粮扔掉。”他说：“不，不，不。”
And then, of course, we pull it apart. Cat food goes flying all over the kitchen. There's little pieces of cat food everywhere, landing in the soup that's boiling over. And then my dad leans down, and he's picking it up and putting pieces of cat food with the hair and aaaaagh! And then, at that moment-- So I go, OK, I'll just pick up my messages. And then I pick up my messages, and I have a message from my gynecologist at 9:30 PM saying, "Call us immediately. We think you have a tumor."
然后，当然了，我们把碗拉开了。猫粮飞得到处都是。到处都是猫粮颗粒，掉进了煮得溢出来的汤里。我爸弯下腰，捡起那些猫粮，连同碎发一起捡……啊！就在那一刻——我去查留言，收到一条我妇产科医生的留言，晚上9:30打的：“立即回电。我们认为你长了肿瘤。”
And while I'm getting that message, my mom's standing there going, "Do you know about a place called House of Blues?" And I'm going, "I'm trying to listen to my messages!" And then the next message is from him going, "Oh, I'm terribly sorry. We've mixed up your results with someone else." So then, I hang up the phone, and I'm going, "Yes, I've heard of the House of Blues."
当我在听那条留言时，我妈站在旁边说：“你知道有个地方叫蓝调之家（House of Blues）吗？”我说：“我在听留言！”下一条留言还是他打的：“噢，非常抱歉。我们把你的结果和别人搞混了。”于是我挂掉电话，说：“是的，我听说过蓝调之家。”
And she goes, "I love blues and gospel. I just love that. I love that music because I just love Gershwin." I don't even anymore-- like, 10 years ago, I would've said, "Gershwin isn't gospel or blues!" But now, I just go, "Oh, I know. The blues and gospel with the Gershwin. Go to the House of Blues. They got it."
她说：“我爱蓝调和福音音乐。我就是爱。我爱那种音乐，因为我爱格什温（Gershwin）。”我甚至懒得解释了——十年前我可能会说：“格什温又不属于福音或蓝调！”但现在，我只能说：“噢，我知道。带格什温的蓝调和福音。去蓝调之家吧，那儿有。”
So I get the cat food out, I break it up, I put it down, the cats are happy. The phone starts ringing, my mom's going, "Do you think House of Blues would be under 'night life' in the Yellow Pages?" "I don't think there's a 'night life' section in the Yellow Pages, but look all you want." And it's my sister calling from Japan. And she's like this, [CRYING] "Hi, I'm so glad you answered the phone, because mom and dad want me to pay them that $48 to the National Geographic subscriptions before they get the bill on their credit card, which I don't think is right. So I have written out a check for them for $100, and I'm going to send it to them with a the note saying, 'I don't want anymore dealings with you.'"
我拿出猫粮，把它分好，放下，猫咪们很开心。电话又响了，我妈问：“你觉得在黄页里蓝调之家会在‘夜生活’分类下吗？”“我不认为黄页里有‘夜生活’分类，你自己找吧。”是我妹妹从日本打来的。她在那儿（哭泣）：“嗨，真高兴你接电话，因为爸妈想让我付那48美元的国家地理杂志订阅费，在他们收到信用卡账单之前，我觉得这不对。所以我给他们写了一张100美元的支票，打算寄过去，附上一张纸条说：‘我不想再和你们有任何瓜葛了。’”
And I just go, "Meg, I cannot talk to you right now." And she goes, "Oh, fine!" And I'm just thinking of her in Japan crying about these [BLEEP] National Geographic subscriptions that no one even wants. I, by the way, am one of the recipients. So isn't it great that I have to get the magazine and know all these trauma and subterfuge that goes on getting the subscription to National Geographic?
我说：“梅格，我现在没法跟你聊这个。”她说：“噢，那就算了！”我脑子里全是她在日本为这些该死的没人想看的《国家地理》杂志痛哭的样子。顺便说一句，我也是订阅者之一。所以，不得不订阅杂志，还要了解订阅过程中的所有创伤和勾心斗角，这难道不是太棒了吗？
Then, I realized the most [BLEEP] up thing I was thinking this week is that I've got to get over, somehow-- because apparently, I refuse to go to therapy, but anyway-- is I've always had this thing where, like my mom-- it started with my mom. Obviously, our tastes and everything were different. Like, I would never decorate the way they did, and all of you, I'm sure, feel the same way. But we'd look at furniture, and I'd go, well, I like the dark wood one, and she'd like, of course, the modern. And she'd always go, "Well, when you get your house, you can have what you want in it."
然后，我意识到这周我想的最他妈离谱的事情是，我必须得克服它——显然，我拒绝去接受心理治疗，但无论如何——我一直有种毛病，就像我妈——这从我妈开始。显然，我们的品味完全不同。比如，我绝不会像他们那样装修，我相信你们大家也一样。我们看家具时，我会说，嗯，我喜欢深色木头那个，她当然喜欢现代风格。她总是说：“好吧，等你有了自己的房子，你可以随心所欲。”
So that was her big thing. Or I'd go, "Why are you yelling at Jimmy"-- my youngest brother-- "this way?" And she'd say, "Well, when you have a child, you can treat him the way you want, but I'm going to--"
这就是她的口头禅。或者我说：“你为什么要这么吼吉米”——我最小的弟弟——“这样对他？”她说：“好吧，等你有了孩子，你想怎么对他都行，但我现在要……”
So I have this mental thing, like I always am trying to be better than some experience in my past. It's like I'm always trying to have a better house to show-- like, my parents are going to learn how to raise kids better because of the way I treat my cats? I don't think so. But I realize the most [BLEEP] up thing is-- oh, just one other thing.
所以我脑子里有个疙瘩，我总是在试图比我过去的经历更好。就像我总是在试图拥有一个更好的房子来展示——难道我父母会因为我对待猫的方式而学会如何更好地抚养孩子吗？我觉得不会。但我意识到最他妈离谱的事情是——哦，还有一件事。
So my brother, they don't know-- now the cancer, they keep taking tests, and the cancer gets less and less, but he seems to be deteriorating anyway. And now they think it's the drugs. So my mom keeps going, "We need to do an intervention with him on the drugs. And he's not going to listen to me, and he's not going to listen to your father. So we've decided you should do it." I'm like, "Well, can I do an intervention on his answering machine? Because I don't have time to really run over there and do this intervention right at this moment." But I realized I was walking around this week thinking, "You know, when I have cancer, I am going to act so much better."
我弟弟的情况——他们不知道——癌症，他们不停地做测试，癌症越来越少，但他看起来还是在恶化。现在他们认为是因为药物。所以我妈不停地说：“我们需要干预他的用药。他不会听我的，也不会听你爸的。所以我们决定你去干预。”我说：“我可以在他的电话录音留言里干预吗？因为我现在没时间跑过去做这种干预。”但我意识到这周我走来走去都在想：“你知道吗，当我得了癌症时，我一定会表现得好得多。”
Well, long after all this, Julia Sweeney said that after she made that comment at Un-Cabaret, when she herself was diagnosed with cancer, people who had been at the club that night would come up to her and remind her what she said. Like, you see? You see? What do you really say to that? Well, coming up, how to make jokes about your own cancer and actually get laughs, an onstage demonstration. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
后来，朱莉娅·斯威尼说，在她那次在“Un-Cabaret”发表那番评论之后，当她自己被诊断出癌症时，那天晚上在俱乐部的人走到她面前提醒她说的话。看吧？看吧？你真的能说什么呢？好吧，接下来，如何拿自己的癌症开玩笑还能让人发笑，现场示范。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And most weeks on our program, we choose some subject and invite a wide variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that subject. And if you're just tuning in, what we're doing is that we are devoting an entire hour to these unusual recordings-- sort of part comedy, part diary-- about cancer. This is Julia Sweeney recorded at Un-Cabaret in Los Angeles.
这里是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种各样的作家和表演者来尝试这个主题。如果你刚调到这个频道，我们正在用整整一个小时的时间来播放这些不寻常的录音——一部分是喜剧，一部分是日记——关于癌症。这是朱莉娅·斯威尼在洛杉矶“Un-Cabaret”录制的。
We have now arrived at Act Two of our program. In this act, Julia gets diagnosed with cancer herself. And one thing that's interesting about these tapes is that once Julia Sweeney actually gets cancer, the stories get less dark. They are less tragic. There is less trouble in them. This next tape is from May of 1995. This is actually the worst sound quality of any of the tapes we're going to play for you today.
我们现在到了节目的第二幕。在这一幕中，朱莉娅被诊断出患有癌症。关于这些录音，有趣的一点是，当朱莉娅·斯威尼真正患上癌症后，故事反而没那么阴暗了。它们没那么悲惨，麻烦也没那么多了。下一段录音来自1995年5月。这实际上是我们今天要给你们播放的录音中音质最差的一段。
And just one quick word for public radio listeners who perhaps do not watch as much television as many Americans do. SNL -- she refers to SNL. SNL, in this context, is Saturday Night Live.
给那些可能不像许多美国人那样看电视的公共广播听众提个醒。《周六夜现场》——她提到的SNL——在这种语境下就是《周六夜现场》。
So about a month ago, I was diagnosed with cancer. Hold for laugh. All right. I wake up debating how and if I should bring that up. But the thing is, it's not life-threatening and I'm totally fine. And you know, in a way, I'm kind of happy for the experience. But my parents, who are staying with me way too long, and at the tail end of when they were going to be with me, then I got cervical cancer.
所以大约一个月前，我被诊断出患有癌症。（停顿，等待笑声）好了。我醒来时还在纠结该怎么提起这件事，甚至纠结要不要提起。但问题是，它并不危及生命，而且我完全没事。你知道，某种程度上，我甚至有点庆幸有这个经历。但我父母——他们在像赖在我家太久了，就在他们快要离开的尾声，我得了宫颈癌。
And so, of course, they wanted to stay longer, which is the last thing I wanted was my parents to stay [BLEEP] longer with me. And then I kept thinking, "How can I lie about my cervical cancer to my parents?" And I'm, like, 35. Can't I just have cancer on my own?"
所以，当然，他们想待得更久，这是我最不希望的事。我心想：“我怎么才能对我父母撒谎说我得了宫颈癌？我已经35岁了，我不能自己一个人得癌症吗？”
So I had to get this radical hysterectomy, which now that I'm in this whole cancer thing, radical doesn't mean far out in the medical world. I just want to let you know. Anyway, so then my mom, they just make me more nervous than calm. I really have friends that would be there and make it a more calm experience. But my mom goes, "I am going to be with you for every doctor appointment and every surgery you're going to have." And then I found myself saying, like, "My friends who've had hysterectomies didn't have to have their moms with them. They had their hysterectomies on their own." And I just realized how [BLEEP] weird that is, but anyway.
所以我不得不做了这个根治性子宫切除术。现在我身处这整个癌症事件中，我知道在医学界，“根治性”并不意味着“远大”。我只是想让你们知道。总之，我妈——他们只会让我更紧张而不是冷静。我确实有朋友能在我身边，让这变得更平静。但我妈说：“我将陪你参加每一次医生预约和每一次手术。”然后我发现自己说：“我的那些做过子宫切除术的朋友都不需要她们的妈妈陪。她们自己去做的。”我才意识到这他妈有多诡异，总之。
And I feel I wouldn't have chosen to have a hysterectomy, I guess. But I kind of feel about my reproductive organs like a bicycle that I've had in the garage, this really great bike that I've just never used. But I want to, you know? But I just never had time. And it's a really good bike. And it's in the garage, and I haven't really been maintaining it. It's all rusty now and everything. But it's there, and I bought it. And it's there. I have a garage for it. And now, I feel like fate is saying to me, "OK, we're taking away your bicycle. You can never ride a bike again." And so then  you think, "god, I was really going to ride that bike."
我不认为我会选择做子宫切除术。但我对我的生殖器官的感觉，就像车库里有一辆我从来没骑过的绝佳自行车。我想骑，你知道吗？但我从来没时间。这是一辆很好的自行车，放在车库里，我从来没保养过，现在锈迹斑斑。但它在那儿，我买了它。我有个车库放它。现在，我觉得命运在对我说：“好了，我们要收回你的自行车了。你再也不能骑车了。”然后你会想：“天哪，我本来真的打算骑那辆车的。”
But it's not like the end of the world. It's like, well, there's a lot of other things. You can skate. Well, I can take the metaphor forever, but anyway. But young men-- especially at SNL , these young, 22-year-old writers they hire at SNL , they would call and go, [SOUNDING DEVASTATED] "I heard that you were having a hysterectomy." I'd go, "Yeah, well, you know, I don't feel that sad about it." And they'd go, "That is the most tragic thing." These [BLEEP] guys. I'd go, "That's right, because now my worth as a woman has been taken away from me." And they'd go, "Mm-hmm." They don't even realize I'm being sarcastic!
但这并不像世界末日。就像，嗯，还有很多别的事情。你可以滑冰。好吧，我可以永远使用这个比喻，总之。但年轻男人——特别是在SNL的那些22岁的年轻作家，他们会打电话过来（声音沮丧地）：“听说你要做子宫切除术了。”我说：“是啊，嗯，你知道，我不觉得那么难过。”他们说：“那真是最悲惨的事。”这些混蛋。我说：“没错，因为现在我作为一个女性的价值被夺走了。”他们说：“嗯。”他们甚至没意识到我在反讽！
And then, I would meet women-- women aren't that much better-- who would have these big new-age solutions. They'd go, "You know, my friend had cervical cancer, and they told her that she had to have a hysterectomy. And she drank carrot juice every day and did yoga. And now she's had seven children." And I'm like, "Get me to the hospital!" Really? Aaagh!
然后，我会遇到一些女性——女性也没好到哪儿去——她们会有那些宏大的新时代解决方案。她们会说：“你知道吗，我朋友得了宫颈癌，医生让她做子宫切除术。结果她每天喝胡萝卜汁、做瑜伽。现在她生了七个孩子。”我心想：“快送我去医院吧！”真的吗？啊！
I'll just do two more little cancer bits before I'm done. So I'm in the hospital. And they save my ovaries, which I guess is a good thing-- I'm learning all about these biological things-- because the ovaries are the things that make you lubricate when you're aroused, which, by the way, is a very important thing. And if I wanted to have a child surrogately, I could have it. So that was fine. They saved those.
在我结束之前，我再讲两段癌症相关的小事。我在医院里。他们保留了我的卵巢，我觉得这是件好事——我正在学习所有这些生物学知识——因为卵巢是让你在兴奋时分泌润滑液的器官，顺便一提，这非常重要。如果我想通过代孕生孩子，我可以。所以那挺好的。他们保留了那些。
But then they didn't know, because I had to have radiation, if it was going to get hit. So they moved my ovaries nine inches up from their normal spot. And then, they said, "Well, if you're really concerned about having a kid with a surrogate, we can harvest 12 eggs now, and we can freeze them for you." And I said, "Oh, OK." And they go, "But the problem is, you have to have the sperm with them in order to freeze them. They can't just be frozen eggs. They have to be fertilized eggs." So I go, "Oh, OK."
但因为我要接受放射治疗，他们不知道卵巢会不会受影响。所以他们把我的卵巢向上移了九英寸。然后他们说：“好吧，如果你真的很担心通过代孕生孩子，我们现在可以采集12个卵子，然后帮你冷冻起来。”我说：“噢，好吧。”他们说：“但问题是，为了冷冻它们，你必须要有精子。它们不能只是冷冻卵子，必须是受精卵。”我说：“噢，好吧。”
And then they go, "OK, so are you married?" "No." "Are you going out with somebody?" "Well, kind of." But you know, "Hey, on Friday, before we see French Kiss, could you just fertilize 12 eggs? You know, I know it might not work out. We're just kind of dating, but--"
然后他们说：“好了，你结婚了吗？”“没有。”“你在跟人约会吗？”“嗯，差不多吧。”但我心想，“嘿，周五看《法兰西之吻》之前，你能顺便帮我把12个卵子受精吗？我知道这可能不成。我们只是在约会，但……”
So I go, "How many different sperm people can I have?" And they go, "Well, the start-up costs are kind of high, but you could have five or six." So I could have two eggs per guy. So I thought, OK, so now I feel like I have this dance card with 12 eggs on it. It's like, "If you're nice enough to me, you can have one of my eggs."
我说：“我能找多少个提供精子的人？”他们说：“嗯，启动成本有点高，但你可以找五六个。”所以我可以每个男的两颗卵子。所以我想，好吧，现在感觉我手里有一张写着12个卵子的舞会名单。就像是，“如果你对我够好，你可以拥有我的一颗卵子。”
Anyway, then I just decided that it's just too weird. So I didn't do that. So then the next thing-- this happened only two days ago-- I went into my radiation doctor. And they had to do all these x-rays and MRIs to make sure that my ovaries were out of the way of the radiation. And they cut my fallopian tubes and my uterus is out and all that stuff.
总之，我后来觉得这实在太诡异了。所以我没那么做。下一件事——这只发生在两天前——我去了放射科医生那儿。他们必须做所有的X光和核磁共振，确保我的卵巢避开了辐射范围。而且他们切断了我的输卵管，移除了子宫等等。
So they come in and they go, "We have some bad news. We've lost one of your ovaries." And I go, "Oh, it died?" And they go, "No, we've lost it." And I go, "You what?" And they go, "We can't find it." I go, "You moved them up 10 inches. Aren't they like here or something?" And they go, "Well, one is there." He goes, "Sometimes, ovaries, when they're cut off from their responsibilities, go traveling." And I go, "That ovary! So caught up with that fallopian his whole life, responsible to that damn uterus." He goes, "Oh, it might show up. And it could just go floating through someday, somewhere." I go, "Am I going to cough, and is the ovary-- should I--"
他们进来后说：“我们有个坏消息。我们弄丢了你的一颗卵巢。”我说：“噢，它坏死了吗？”他们说：“不，我们弄丢了它。”我说：“你什么？”他们说：“我们找不到它了。”我说：“你们把它移上去10英寸。它们不是就在这儿某处吗？”他们说：“嗯，一颗在那儿。”他说：“有时候，卵巢在失去职责后，会去旅行。”我说：“那颗卵巢！这一辈子都被输卵管纠缠，对那该死的子宫负责。”他说：“噢，它可能会出现的。它可能某天会漂到某处。”我说：“我会咳嗽，然后那颗卵巢——我该……”
That was May of 1995. This next moment is a little further into her treatment-- a month later. And just a quick warning, some of the language here may not be suitable for younger listeners.
那是1995年5月的录音。下一段是在她治疗更深入的时候——一个月后。给你们提个醒，这儿的一些语言可能不太适合年幼的听众。
All right. Oh, I had my vagina tattooed. It's true. Some people say, you know, "I love Tom." Mine says "aim the beams here." I have a little cancer. So I had to have a hysterectomy, and now I'm having radiation. Everything seems to be fine, and I'm on the gazillionth percentile of making it. But it doesn't mean that I don't have to have eight weeks of radiation. So right now, I'm in the fourth week.
好了。哦，我在我的阴道上纹了个身。是真的。有些人会说：“我爱汤姆。”我的写着“瞄准这里”。我得了点癌症。所以我必须做子宫切除术，现在在做放射治疗。一切看起来都很好，我康复的几率很大。但这并不意味着我不必接受八周的放疗。我现在在第四周。
So when you get radiation, you have to get a tattoo on the area that you're getting radiated. So mine's kind of a really sensitive spot. So I was a little scared. But they're saying, "Oh, no. It'll hurt, but who cares" or something like that. "Don't worry. It'll hurt a lot."
做放疗时，你必须在要接受照射的区域纹个身。我的纹在了比较敏感的地方。所以我有点害怕。但他们说：“噢，没关系。会疼，但谁在乎呢。”之类的。“别担心，这会很疼。”
So I had to lay there with my pants off. And then they brought in a tattoo artist. There's a person who tattoos you. So this guy, at first, he was kind of smiling at me a little too much, like maybe he recognized me from SNL, but I wasn't sure. And I'm not going to really bring it up. And he's not saying anything. But he gave me that kind of look like, "Hi!" And I was like, "Does everyone who gets radiation get that look?" But anyway.
我不得不脱了裤子躺在那儿。然后他们带进了一个纹身师。有个专门负责纹身的人。所以这家伙，起初，他冲我笑得有点太多了，就像他认出了我曾在SNL待过，但我不敢肯定。我没打算提起这事。他也没说话。但他给了我那种“嗨！”的眼神。我在想：“每个做放疗的人都会得到那种眼神吗？”总之。
So then, he's tattooing my vagina. So we're spending some time together. And he's down there, doing it. And I just find it so funny that it was hard not to laugh, but you can't laugh because it has to be a really specific spot. But then I keep thinking, "My vagina is getting a tattoo."
所以，他在我的阴道上纹身。我们待在一起一段时间。他在下面忙活。我觉得这实在太搞笑了，很难不笑出来，但你不能笑，因为它必须纹在非常精确的位置。但我一直想：“我的阴道在纹身。”
And then, all of a sudden, he's going like this, and then he goes, "I think the best one is when Pat went to the barber." [BLEEP], you know? I'm like, "Yeah, that was a good one too. I think the kicker is now that Pat has cervical cancer, we know what--" This is so personal. I can't even believe I'm telling you guys this, but I guess that's the whole point of Un-Cabaret, even though it'll make you uncomfortable.
突然，他一边这样，一边说：“我觉得最棒的一段是帕特去理发店的那集。”他妈的，你知道吗？我心想：“是啊，那段确实好。笑点在于现在帕特得了宫颈癌，我们知道……”这太私密了。我甚至不敢相信我在告诉你们这些，但这大概就是“Un-Cabaret”的意义所在，尽管它会让你们感到不舒服。
So the first half is external radiation, where they beam you from the outside. And then the second half that I start next week is internal radiation. Think about it. OK, so I call it the "dildo of radiation." And in fact, I insist on referring to it as the "dildo of radiation," and the doctors get really upset. Because I go, "When do we start the dildo of radiation?" So I had to go in and get measured, and they had to make this cylinder that fit exactly me and everything.
所以上半部分是体外放射，就是从体外对你进行照射。下半部分我下周开始，是体内放射治疗。你想想看，我把它称为“辐射按摩棒”。事实上，我坚持称之为“辐射按摩棒”，医生们对此非常生气。因为我总会说：“我们什么时候开始用辐射按摩棒？”所以我不得不去进行测量，他们必须定制一个完全贴合我的圆筒之类的东西。
So then I go, "So this dildo of radiation, will it be vibrating?" And then the doctor goes, "Actually, it will be vibrating." And I said, "It will?" It's sick, because the light in this doctor's eyes when he talks about how this is the cutting edge of technology, it scares me because I really feel like that's the point of it is that they get to do this to me. When they go like, "Yes, you really need that, because this is the cutting edge of technology and hardly anyone's gotten this and we're really working on it!" Do I really need it?
然后我就说：“那么这个辐射按摩棒，它会振动吗？”医生说：“确实，它会振动。”我说：“真的吗？”这太疯狂了，因为当医生谈到这是尖端技术时，他眼中的光让我感到害怕，因为我真的觉得，他们之所以这么做，就是为了能对我实施这种治疗。当他们说：“是的，你确实需要这个，因为这是尖端技术，几乎没人用过，我们正在全力研发！”我真的需要它吗？
Anyway, so I have to go. So then last week, they're trying to prepare me for it and everything. And they go, "Well, you know, it lasts three hours." Oh my god, yes! So I go, "Three hours?" And they said yes. And I said, oh. And also, I won't get into details, but the other orifices in that area will also be filled with other instruments for three hours.
总之，我必须得去。上周他们试图为我做准备，他们说：“你知道，这需要三个小时。”天哪，真的吗！所以我说：“三个小时？”他们说是。我说，哦。还有，我不详述细节了，但我身体那个区域的其他孔道也要塞入其他仪器，持续三个小时。
And when they said, "You have an option. We can send you to the cancer therapist at Cedars-Sinai to learn visualization techniques, or we can give you an IV of Valium. Actually, I kind of feel bad because they really were trying to push the visualization. So I just went, "I am very good at visualizing. I'm an actress and visualization is my hobby and my expertise." I think when it comes to medical procedures, an IV of Valium is going to work a  lot better than thinking about an ocean.
当他们说：“你可以选。我们可以送你去锡达斯-西奈医疗中心的癌症治疗师那里学习可视化技术，或者我们可以给你静脉注射安定。”其实我觉得有点不好意思，因为他们真的很努力地推销可视化技术。所以我只是说：“我很擅长可视化。我是个演员，可视化是我的爱好也是我的专长。”我觉得在进行医疗手术时，静脉注射安定比想象大海要管用得多。
Oh yeah, this is another sick thing that I do. It's not funny, only sick. I have this thing where the clothes in my closet don't know that I have cancer. And if I haven't worn them since before when I found out I had cancer, I have to tell them when I put my clothes on. So I'll put on a dress, and I'll think, "Oh, this dress doesn't even  know." And so then I'll put on the dress and I'll think, "Oh, dress. Don't you realize what's happened to me?" And the dress goes, "That's terrible, but you'll be OK."
哦对了，这是我做的另一件疯狂的事。这并不好笑，只是很病态。我有种感觉，我衣柜里的衣服不知道我得了癌症。如果我自从发现自己得癌症后就没穿过它们，我穿上的时候就得告诉它们。所以我会穿上一件连衣裙，心想：“哦，这件衣服甚至都不知道。”然后穿上它，我会想：“哦，小裙子，你没意识到我发生了什么吗？”那件裙子会说：“那太糟糕了，但你会好起来的。”
OK, well, that was June 4, 1995. Not long after that, Julia Sweeney returned to Un-Cabaret. She was getting her treatment, still. And she was getting her treatment at one hospital, and her brother was getting treated at another hospital. And her case, apparently, was this very rare type of cervical cancer. And it turned out that the one doctor in this world who was studying this particular type of cancer happened to be located at his hospital, not at hers. And so at some point, slides of her cells were shipped over to his hospital. And then they were going to do some procedure on her, so she had to get the slides back so they could do this procedure. And she offered to go and fetch the slides herself.
好的，那是1995年6月4日。在那之后不久，朱莉娅·斯威尼（Julia Sweeney）回到了“Un-Cabaret”剧场。她当时还在接受治疗。她在一家医院治疗，她弟弟在另一家医院治疗。她的病例似乎是一种非常罕见的宫颈癌。结果发现，世界上唯一一位正在研究这种特定癌症的医生恰好在她弟弟的医院，而不是她所在的医院。所以后来，她的细胞切片被运到了那个医生所在的医院。他们打算对她进行某种手术，所以她必须拿回切片才能进行。于是她提出亲自去取回这些切片。
I didn't know where I was going. All I knew is his name was Dr. Fu. So I go over, and it's not really part of the hospital where the research is done. It's in this other building, and it's all restricted areas. And I just kept going through doors and doors where people were wearing more and more green things. And more people had masks and stuff. And I was knocking on doors. And everyone was so confused about what I wanted. And I'd have to say, "Hi, I'm looking for the Julia Sweeney cancer slides." And they'd all go, "Oh, for who?" And I'd say, "For Julia Sweeney-- me." And they'd go, oh.
我不知道要去哪儿。我只知道他的名字叫傅医生。我去了那里，但那地方并不是医院里进行研究的区域。它在另一栋楼里，全是禁区。我穿过一道又一道门，里面的人穿着越来越多绿色的防护服。更多的人戴着口罩之类的东西。我在敲门。每个人都很困惑我想要什么。我不得不说：“嗨，我在找朱莉娅·斯威尼的癌症切片。”他们都会问：“哦，为了谁？”我会说：“为了朱莉娅·斯威尼——也就是我。”然后他们就会说，哦。
And then finally, I found this Dr. Fu's door, and I knocked on it. And this little Asian man opens the door, and it's literally out of a movie. There's books to the ceiling and cobwebs and a little microscope. And he goes, "Yes?" And I said, "Yes, I hear that you have the Julia Sweeney cancer slides." And he says, "Yes." And I go, "Yes, I've come here to pick them up."
最后，我找到了傅医生的门，敲了敲。一个小个子的亚洲男人打开了门，简直就像电影里的场景。书堆到了天花板，还有蜘蛛网和一台显微镜。他说：“是的？”我说：“是的，我听说你有朱莉娅·斯威尼的癌症切片。”他说：“有的。”我说：“是的，我来这里取它们。”
And he said, "Oh, what project are you working on?" And I said, "Oh, the Julia Sweeney project." And he said, "No, no, no. I mean what research area are you in? And I said, "No, I mean I'm Julia Sweeney." And he said, "What?" And I said, "Yeah, those slides, that's me. Those slides are me. And I want them. Give them back!"
他说：“哦，你在做什么项目？”我说：“哦，朱莉娅·斯威尼项目。”他说：“不，不，不。我是说你是哪个研究领域的？”我说：“不，我的意思是，我就是朱莉娅·斯威尼。”他说：“什么？”我说：“是的，那些切片，那就是我。那些切片就是我。我想要它们。还给我！”
And he goes, "You're the person in these slides?" He goes, "Yeah, they're right here." He picks up the slides. And I go, "Yeah." And he goes, "You're this person?" And I go, "Yeah." And he goes, "Oh my god." He goes, "I have been getting grants to study this special kind of cancer for 20 years. And only 50 women in the world have been diagnosed with this special kind of cancer. And you're one of the ones I'm studying, and I've never met in the flesh any of the women that have ever had this cancer except for you."
他说：“你就是切片里的那个人？”他说：“是的，它们就在这儿。”他拿起切片。我说：“是的。”他说：“你就是这个人？”我说：“是的。”他说：“天哪。”他说：“我获得拨款研究这种特殊癌症已经20年了。全世界只有50名女性被诊断出患有这种特殊的癌症。你就是我正在研究的对象之一，除了你之外，我从未在现实生活中见过任何患过这种癌症的女性。”
And I said, "Oh." And he's like, "Oh, please come in and sit down." And he said, "Well, how does it feel to have this cancer?" And I said, "Well, you know, I actually have no symptoms. It's kind of hilarious that I just have no symptoms. It seems like all of the problems have been coming from the cure of this, but not from the actual cancer."
我说：“哦。”他说：“哦，请进，请坐。”他说：“那么，患上这种癌症感觉如何？”我说：“嗯，你知道，我其实没有任何症状。有趣的是我竟然没有任何症状。所有的麻烦似乎都来自治疗，而不是癌症本身。”
And he goes, "Oh, there's only 50 women in the world, and none of them have died from it." And I go, "Oh, you can always hope." And I go, "Oh, great." And he wanted to know if I'd been on birth control pills, because that's what he thinks it was related to, which I had. And he's asking me, "What are your habits?" And I go, "Well, I like to run and ski. Maybe people who run and ski and take birth control pills get this cancer."
他说：“哦，全世界只有50名女性，没有一个人死于这种病。”我说：“哦，你总是可以抱有希望的。”我说：“哦，太棒了。”他想知道我是否服用过避孕药，因为他认为这与此有关，我确实服用过。他问我：“你有什么习惯吗？”我说：“嗯，我喜欢跑步和滑雪。也许跑步、滑雪还服用避孕药的人会得这种癌症。”
And then he goes, "Well, can I take you out for some coffee or something?" And I said yeah. And then we went and had this coffee, and he was just so happy to be with me, like, meeting this woman who had the cancer.
然后他说：“那个，我能请你喝杯咖啡之类的吗？”我说好。然后我们去喝了咖啡，他真的很高兴能和我在一起，就像见到一个患有这种癌症的女人一样。
OK, well, then I found out a few weeks later, after the slides went back, that I didn't have that cancer. I had a different kind of really rare cervical cancer, but not that specific kind. And I don't think they ever really told that guy, because this week, he called me up. And he said, "Hey, how are you doing?" and everything. And I said, "Oh, I'm fine. I did all of the surgeries and the radiation. I'm feeling great." And he said, "That's so great."
好的，后来几周后，切片送回去之后，我发现我并没有那种癌症。我患的是另一种非常罕见的宫颈癌，但不是那种特定的。我觉得他们可能从没告诉过那个人，因为这周他给我打了电话。他说：“嘿，你怎么样？”之类的。我说：“哦，我很好。我做了所有的手术和放疗。我感觉棒极了。”他说：“那太好了。”
And then I realized that I was too embarrassed to tell him I didn't have his cancer. I go, "Yeah." And he goes, "Well, I'm really glad. No one who's had that cancer has died. They've had to go through hell, but they haven't died." And then I just had to play into it. And then I realized that I'm so co-dependent that I didn't want him to think that I didn't have the cancer he was studying. I had to pretend. So sick.
然后我意识到，我太尴尬了，没法告诉他我没有他研究的那种癌症。我说：“是啊。”他说：“我真的很高兴。没有患那种癌症的人死亡。她们虽然经历了地狱般的折磨，但她们没有死。”然后我只能顺着他说。我意识到我是个共生依赖症患者，我不想让他觉得我没有患他正在研究的癌症。我不得不假装。真病态。
All these stories that we've been hearing began in 1994. And finally, in July of 1995, Julia Sweeney took the stage at Un-Cabaret to announce--
我们听到的所有这些故事都始于1994年。最终，在1995年7月，朱莉娅·斯威尼在“Un-Cabaret”舞台上宣布——
I don't have cancer anymore. I only say this because-- I don't know if anyone was here for other sets where I talked about it-- but I got a little cancer. And I did surgery, and I did radiation. And my last radiation was on Wednesday. And so now I can't say I have cancer anymore, which I have to say, I will totally cop to the fact that I'm kind of missing that, because I just loved not necessarily doing, but having that moment where I could say, "I don't know if you've heard, but I have cancer."
我不再有癌症了。我之所以这么说，是因为——我不知道是否有人听过我谈论此事的其他片段——我得了一点癌症。我做了手术，做了放疗。我最后一次放疗是在周三。所以现在我不能再说我有癌症了，我得说，我完全承认我有点怀念那个状态，因为我真的很喜欢那种时刻，哪怕不是为了做什么，就是能说出：“我不知道你听说了没，但我得了癌症。”
But now I can say, "I am in remission." I guess that's the term, although no doctor has even said that to me. They just said, "All right, you did enough. See you later." I said, "Don't you mean to tell me I'm in remission?"
但现在我可以说了，“我处于缓解期。”我想这是那个术语，尽管没有医生跟我说过。他们只是说：“好了，你做得够多了。回头见。”我说：“你难道不应该告诉我我处于缓解期吗？”
So on Wednesday, I had to have my last radiation. And it's this kind of horrible ordeal that lasts three hours and is very personally invasive into certain orifices of your body. Imagine. See, for my surgery-- this is how sick I am-- I had horrible abdominal surgery, and it was incredibly painful, tubes coming out of me.
所以周三，我做了最后一次放疗。这是一种可怕的考验，持续三个小时，非常深入地侵入你身体的某些孔道。想象一下。你看，对于我的手术——我就是病得这么重——我做了可怕的腹部手术，非常痛苦，身上插着管子。
And they gave me Percocet and codeine and everything. And I would be in excruciating pain and not take my pain pills to save them for a day when I'd enjoy them more. That's when my parents were staying with me, and I'd be going, "Aaaaaaa!" And my mother would go, "Take the codeine." And I'd go, "There will be a day when, mixed with a margarita, I will be so much happier."
他们给了我扑热息痛和可待因之类的药。我疼得要命，却不吃止痛药，想留着它们等哪天能更享受的时候再吃。那时我父母和我住在一起，我疼得大叫：“啊啊啊！”我母亲会说：“吃点可待因吧。”我会说：“总有一天，把它和玛格丽特酒混在一起喝，我会快乐得多。”
Julia Sweeney survived her cancer and turned these monologues from Un-Cabaret into a one-woman show called God Said, "Ha!" Back in the 1990s, it played in Los Angeles, it played on Broadway at the Lyceum Theater. Julia put it out as a book. Quentin Tarantino turned it into a movie that you can still get on DVD.
朱莉娅·斯威尼战胜了癌症，并将这些来自“Un-Cabaret”的独白改编成了一部名为《上帝说：“哈！”》的独角戏。90年代，它在洛杉矶上演，并在百老汇的莱塞姆剧院演出。朱莉娅把它写成了书。昆汀·塔伦蒂诺把它拍成了电影，你现在还能买到DVD。
Anyway, Julia's brother did not survive his cancer. He died two weeks after she was diagnosed. But we thought we'd end our program today with a story from January of 1995. This is taped before Julia knew that she had cancer. And when this was recorded, her brother was still alive, and family was really struggling.
总之，朱莉娅的弟弟没能战胜他的癌症。他在朱莉娅被确诊两周后去世了。但我们今天想用1995年1月的一个故事来结束我们的节目。这是在朱莉娅知道自己患癌之前录制的。录音时，她弟弟还活着，家人正处于极度挣扎之中。
So anyway, this is not even funny. OK, I'll just tell it really quick. I went to another audition. It was actually a meeting. I felt like it went really well, and it was like, wow, this is a possibility, and this is great. And I'm driving back from Santa Monica, feeling so happy for the first time in a really long time because my parents are living with me. And I'm so happy.
总之，这甚至不好笑。好吧，我很快讲完。我去了另一场试镜。其实是一次会面。我觉得进行得很顺利，感觉，哇，这很有可能，这太棒了。我开车从圣莫尼卡回来，这么长一段时间以来第一次感到如此幸福，因为我父母和我住在一起。我太开心了。
And so I walk in the door, and as I walk in the door, I hear my mother yelling at my brother. "You're drunk. That's what it is." Like some sort of awful Arthur Miller play or something. So then I come in, and I go, "Hi." And she goes, "How was your meeting?" And I go, "It was good." And she goes, "Well, your brother's been drinking. And he is D-R-U-N-K. Then my brother-- oh, this story is too sad. I have to stop it.
我走进门，刚进门就听到我母亲冲我弟弟大喊。“你喝醉了。就是这样。”就像某种可怕的阿瑟·米勒的戏剧一样。我进来后，我说：“嗨。”她说：“你的会面怎么样？”我说：“很好。”她说：“好吧，你弟弟一直在喝酒。他醉得一塌糊涂。”然后我弟弟——哦，这个故事太悲伤了。我得停下来。
OK, well, let's just say this. My brother leaves the room and starts smoking pot in the other room. And then my mom's going on and on, and she doesn't know how to tell stories correctly. And I know you're thinking it's a familial trait. But she'll say, "Oh, I have to tell you the most important thing. I went to Pavilions, and I ran into this couple from the Balkans. And your father was reading that book. And then I couldn't find the change for the ten, and then the car, and so--" And I just go, "Oh, huh. When you can't find your change and you meet someone from the Balkans at the store, and why are you talking to people at Pavilions?"
好吧，我们就这么说吧。我弟弟离开房间，开始在另一个房间抽大麻。然后我妈还在喋喋不休，她根本不知道怎么正确地讲故事。我知道你在想这是一种家族特征。但她会说：“哦，我必须告诉你最重要的事情。我去了Pavilions超市，遇到了那对来自巴尔干半岛的夫妇。你爸爸在读那本书。然后我找不到十块钱的零钱，然后车子，然后——”我就说：“哦，嗯。当你找不到零钱还在超市遇到巴尔干人时，为什么你要在超市跟人搭话呢？”
So I just walk out of the house and go to the office where my dad is. And my dad goes, "Oh, hi. I borrowed this book off your shelf-- The Balkan Ghost, which is all travel essays written by this reporter about his travels in the Balkans. And those Balkan people, they're crazy. Did you know about Adam the Impaler, who impaled people?" And I go, "Oh, no."
所以我走出家门，去了我爸爸所在的办公室。我爸爸说：“哦，嗨。我从你书架上借了这本书——《巴尔干幽灵》，全是那个记者关于他在巴尔干旅行的游记。那些巴尔干人，他们疯了。你知道穿刺公亚当吗，那个把人刺穿的人？”我说：“哦，不。”
And then he says, "Oh, and it reminded me of this other book Rebecca West wrote, this great travelogue that was written in 1937 about her travels in the Balkans, and it really foretold a lot of stuff. And do you know that every major war is started in the Balkans?" And we had this nice little conversation. And he's like, "And how was your meeting?" And I go, "Oh, it was really good." And he goes, "Oh, I'm so glad."
然后他说：“哦，这让我想起了丽贝卡·韦斯特写的另一本书，那是1937年写的一本很棒的游记，关于她在巴尔干的旅行，它确实预言了很多事情。你知道吗，每场重大战争都是在巴尔干半岛发起的？”我们进行了愉快的交谈。他说：“你的会面怎么样？”我说：“哦，非常好。”他说：“哦，我真高兴。”
Then I come back in the house. Mom goes, "I need to talk to you in the bedroom." So I go-- oh, I'd better go quick because this is so sad-- so I go into the bedroom, and she goes, "Your father is driving me crazy, and I'm leaving him. But I'm not leaving your house, and neither is he." I go, "So what does that mean?" She goes, "It means I am not sleeping in the guest room with him anymore. I need another place to sleep."
然后我回到屋里。妈妈说：“我需要在卧室和你谈谈。”我——哦，我得快点说，因为这太令人难过了——我走进卧室，她说：“你父亲快把我逼疯了，我要离开他。但我不会离开你的房子，他也不会。”我说：“那是什么意思？”她说：“这意味着我不会再和他睡在客房里了。我需要另一个地方睡觉。”
And I'm thinking, "OK, the brother from Washington is sleeping on the sofa in my office. I'm sleeping in the dining room. My other brother is in my bedroom. My parents are in the guest room.
我在想，“好吧，从华盛顿来的弟弟睡在我办公室的沙发上。我睡在餐厅里。我另一个弟弟在我卧室里。我父母在客房里。”
And I just go, "Married people who visit me must sleep together. I do not have enough beds for people to break up while they're visiting me. You must overcome your feelings and just sleep in the same bed. Go in after he's fallen asleep, and get up before he wakes up. And don't touch him in the night, but you've got to stay in the room!"
我说：“来访的夫妻必须睡在一起。我没有足够的床位让他们在做客时分居。你们必须克服情绪，睡在同一张床上。等他睡着后再进去，在他醒来前起床。晚上别碰他，但你们必须待在那个房间里！”
Anyway, so mom sleeps on the couch in the living room. Dad's in the guest room. So we're all in different places. So then, at 5:00 in the morning, I notice the TV pops on, and In a Lonely Place is starting at 5:00 in the morning. Irony. And my mom sits up, and she's going, "What's this?" And there must've been something where I programmed the TV to tape something. She yells from the living room, she goes, "Julie, there's a movie on about a lonely people. What is it?"
总之，我妈睡在客厅沙发上。我爸在客房。所以我们都在不同的地方。然后，凌晨5点，我注意到电视打开了，凌晨5点开始播放《孤独的地方》。真讽刺。我妈坐起来，问道：“这是什么？”肯定是我设置了电视录制什么东西。她在客厅大喊：“朱莉，有个关于孤独的人的电影在播。是什么？”
It's like 5:00 in the morning, so I go, "Oh, In a Lonely Place. Yeah, Nicholas Ray and great film noir, Humphrey Bogart." And she goes, "You know, he was a drunk. In real life, too." And I go, "Oh." "And Gloria Grahame." Anyway, so slowly, the whole family gets up. And then, all of a sudden, it's me, my two brothers, and my mom and dad. And we all watch In a Lonely Place . This is yesterday morning from 5:00 to 7:00 AM.
那时大约凌晨5点，我说：“哦，《孤独的地方》。是的，尼古拉斯·雷导演，伟大的黑色电影，亨弗莱·鲍嘉主演。”她说：“你知道吗，他在现实生活中也是个酒鬼。”我说：“哦。”“还有格洛丽亚·格雷厄姆。”总之，全家人慢慢都起来了。突然间，我和两个弟弟，还有我爸妈，我们都在看《孤独的地方》。这就是昨天凌晨5点到7点发生的事。
Julia Sweeney at Un-Cabaret in Los Angeles. Lately, Julia has been working on a new one-woman show, that we've actually excerpted on This American Life already, called Letting Go of God . Next month, she plans to put out that show on CD. She's got plans to film that show. There's a book in the works, more live performances, the whole schmear. For details, you can go to her website with the incredibly difficult-to-remember name, www.juliasweeney.com.
朱莉娅·斯威尼在洛杉矶的“Un-Cabaret”。最近，朱莉娅一直在制作一部新的独角戏，我们已经在《美国生活》节目中摘录过部分内容，名为《放手上帝》。下个月，她计划发行该剧的CD。她打算拍摄那场演出。还有一本书正在筹备中，会有更多的现场表演，全套都有。详情请访问她那名字极其难记的网站，www.juliasweeney.com。
Today's program was produced by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel, Dolores Wilber, and Peter Clowney. Contributing editors for this show, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Paul Tough. Production help for today's show by [UNINTELLIGIBLE] January and Seth Lind.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我本人制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Dolores Wilber）和彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）参与制作。本节目的特约编辑是杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。今天的节目制作协助由[听不清] January和塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）完成。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If today's program has made you curious about Un-Cabaret, they have audio downloads, greatest hits CDs, live shows that they are still doing Los Angeles. Details about all that on the web at www.uncabaret.com.
如果今天的节目让你对“Un-Cabaret”产生了好奇，他们有音频下载、精选CD，并且在洛杉矶依然有现场演出。详情请访问网站 www.uncabaret.com。
Music help for today's program by Jessica Hopper and by the mysterious and elusive [? Rumpety Rattles. ?] Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to 10 years of our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
今天节目的音乐协助由杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）和神秘莫测的[? Rumpety Rattles ?]提供。我们的网站是 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们过去10年的节目或购买CD。或者你也可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载今天的节目和我们的档案。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who believes that radio is not a vast information expressway bringing you news and stories and music.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他认为广播不是带给你新闻、故事和音乐的浩瀚信息高速公路。
"No, I think it's more like a spigot."
“不，我觉得它更像是一个水龙头。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），下周将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。